[Music]
this is a country that's really close to
united states and the EPA's governance
affects us directly the science and this
evidence is a common human heritage and
so it doesn't just belong to the US
origin people deals
[Music]
we're concerned that with the changing
political climate in the united states
that important data sets such as the
ones of the EPA produce may not be
available in the future and so we're
trying to make sure if those data sets
are available to every season I have no
idea what the trump administration is
likely to do some but I'm definitely
concerned that it's not as friendly to
scientific researches previous
administrations have been and I strongly
believe that political decisions need to
be based on very good evidence and
agencies like EPA and other ones like it
are in the business of creating good
data and good evidence that people can
make smart decisions based on
[Music]